hello ma'am it has been a minute
i know right oh my goodness oh my gosh
forever
it's over though it's over i mean i i
can't imagine what it's like for you but
what a moment to be america's favorite
with nearly one million votes
the winner is congratulations davon
ugly crap you looked like your jaw was
on the floor when it was announced what
was going through your mind when julie
called your name
um first of all wow because
you know tonight history was made you
know there's never been an
african-american
you know america's favorite ever and so
when i found out i was in the top two
against tyler i was like okay yeah
that's good i was thanking god for just
being in the top two
but then when she said my name i said
wait a minute
oh oh my gosh like i have no
words and i'm just i just think of every
african-american that house guest that
has walked through those doors like
this is for y'all like this is for us
like we did so
good i'm this is for us like it's a us
thing you know so i'm excited i'm
excited and i'm so grateful to everybody
that voted like
my goodness my heart is beating so fast
i mean that energy that you just showed
me that
inclusiveness i think that's exactly why
people love you so much among many other
things
over 1 million votes fans alumni were
campaigning for you how does it feel to
be that beloved
i honestly thought that they were going
to be mad at me because i know a lot of
them were like
girl you suck at this game
so my mind is blown but again i'm so
grateful
my god like i'm so grateful and that
lets me know
that you know me taking advantage
of the opportunity to use this platform
for something greater than just the game
wasn't in vain and i'm thank god i'm
thanking god that people were touched
by the conversations that were being had
in the house you know so that makes me
feel good
well we do got to talk a little bit
about uh the game and everything that's
going on
you voted for cody even after him saying
that you weren't friends as you
mentioned
why did you vote for him well i'm not a
hater so you know
brenda knott he played a hell of a game
like his resume was
out of control and so even you know when
julie was asking you know
devon who do you think and i was like
well if they're smart they'll vote out
nicole
and the reason i said that is because
some of the people in the jury was
talking about voting for her as a winner
to make it to the end so if you take the
winner out
we knew enzo wasn't going to win it was
a clean sweep
so i'm like what if he's smart nicole
not only lied to me
but she also ignited the fire she
provoked it
and she encouraged it for us to go back
and forth do you think he still would
have won if he took nicole
i don't think i think he still would
have won but i don't think it would have
been a unanimous vote
okay now you said you wanted to have an
important conversation
with christmas did you get to have that
with her no
i have not been able to have a
conversation with christmas yet
you know um i don't know if that
conversation is going to happen i would
love for it to
because there's always room for
education and she admitted that she's
very ignorant to a lot of things and so
i would love to have that conversation
with her
but i don't know if it's going to happen
it's completely up to her but my door is
always open
i don't know what her excitement is
about me
specifically that i'm able to trigger
her by just breathing but you know
it is what it is i ain't got time for
that because she is blessed
okay i can't worry about that i want to
ask you too some viewers were
kind of saying that you know maybe not
enough big moves were made
this summer what would you say to that
criticism i
definitely agree you know which is why
i'm so upset that i lost that hoh in
week five like that was the one because
i was gonna shake the tables
i was gonna put up cody and tyler and i
felt like that would have been
boom the one to shake the tables but it
just
it wasn't and that's another reason why
i wanted janelle to stay because i know
if she could have won something this
season she would have done the same
thing so it just that big alliance
formed and they swept
and as a fan of the show myself i know
that's why
nobody wants to watch that so you know
it's up
so having done it all would you ever
play again a fourth time
not this upcoming summer but the one
after that maybe they could call me
i also want to ask you i mean the memes
of you
we see them everywhere do you have a
favorite
gif or meme of yourself you're like one
of the most memes players in big brother
history
i'm scared to see what they put together
this season but my favorite will always
be the original and that's me coming out
of the big brother house like that one
is my favorite hands down that's my baby
that's number one so
now i i want to ask you if we have time
um you know you've been gone for a
minute so we're just doing with
everybody a pop culture speed round
so i'm gonna give you just some quick
questions with options
one of these answers is true let me know
which one you think is true what your
best guess is for something that really
happened
while you were gone okay i'm probably
gonna fail but let's do it
which celebrity was a contestant on
dancing with the stars
andrew cuomo carol baskin or lindsay
lohan
probably lindsay lohan it was carol
bachman
tiger king tiger queen i thought about
that but i was like i don't see her
doing wow
[Music]
who got engaged while you were in the
house what celebrity got engaged
taylor swift and her boyfriend joe alwyn
gwen stefani and blake shelton
or camila cabello and shawn mendes
um did taylor swift get her man
and got engaged no she's got him but no
gwen and blake are engaged
i'm proud of her i'm excited for her yay
i told you i'm gonna fail this like i
suck at comps you know this already
but your guesses are really good they
are they're really you're getting you're
getting like second
in any time and which superhero actor
accidentally released a not safe for
work pick on the
internet chris hemsworth chris pratt or
chris
evans
[Music]
chris pratt i would agree with you there
i would have but chris evans chris evans
did it but
we want to see all of them you know i'm
just kidding
i'm the worst at this oh my god okay two
more questions
we'll hit you with two more okay okay
what did katy perry name her baby did
she name her baby
daisy dove lily leaf or rose rain
say the third one again rose rain
[Music]
number two number one but you're doing
so great
and last which famous brit fell off his
motorcycle and broke
his back while you were gone oh no
simon cowell or jude law
was it you law it was simon cowell you
didn't get
any of them right but here's the thing
you have won you are america's favorite
house guest
don't blame me i ain't seen a tv read a
magazine i
did nothing in three months what
what is the first thing you i know you
you want to get to your daughter but
other than that
what's the first thing you want to do if
it's a bite of food or a show you want
to watch or anything what's the first
thing
i want to go to my mama house and have a
seafood boil
i want the works all the crab legs
all the lobster the corn the sausage i
want it all